vous êtes nuls en physique vous vous
trompez tout le temps quand vous faites
des calculs et bien ce que je vais vous
raconter aujourd'hui devrait vous
rassurer
on va parler de la plus grosse erreur de
toute l'histoire de la physique
elle concerne l'expansion de l'univers
et vous allez voir qu'elle est vraiment
vraiment grosse
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose dont vous avez
forcément déjà entendu parler on vit
dans un univers qui est en expansion
c'est à dire que toutes les galaxies
s'éloignent les unes des autres
alors ça on le sait pour deux très
bonnes raisons comme souvent en physique
la première c'est qu'on peut l'observer
et la deuxième c'est qu'on peut le
calculer les observations elles ont été
faites pour la première fois dans les
années 30 par l'astronome américain
edwin hubble
vous savez c'est celui qui a bien plus
tard laissé son nom au télescope spatial
alors à l'époque hubble avait pas de
télescope spatial mais il a été le
premier à pouvoir observer le mouvement
des galaxies et à se rendre compte que
toutes les galaxies s'éloignent les unes
des autres et qu'elles s'éloignaient
d'autant plus vite qu'elle était
distante par ce phénomène d'éloignement
il est à l'origine de l'idée de
l'expansion de l'univers
et je vous ai dit on n'observe pas
seulement mais on peut aussi le calcul
est alors pour faire ça on utilise les
équations d'einstein de la relativité
générale et on les applique aux cas de
l'univers dans son ensemble et ses
équations elles permettent de calculer à
quelle vitesse les galaxies s'éloignent
et ses équations elles sont parfaites
accord avec ce qu observer hubble
puisqu'elle disent que les galaxies
s'éloignent
avec une vitesse qui est proportionnelle
à leurs distances il faut quand même
raconter quelque chose à propos de
l'expansion de l'univers
vous savez on présente souvent einstein
comme le type qui avait toujours raison
qui s'est jamais trompé et c est bien
s'il ya bien un point sur lequel
einstein s'est bien planté c'est
l'expansion de l'univers
en fait plusieurs années avant les
observations de hubble
einstein s'était déjà rendu compte que
ses propres équation pouvait conduire à
l'idée d'un univers qui ne soit pas
statique c'est à dire qu'ils soient
éventuellement en expansion en
contraction
et ça pour lui c'était un truc
totalement inconcevable et donc il s'est
dit que sa théorie était forcément
fausse et il a cherché à modifier ses
équations pour qu'elle puisse donner un
univers qu'ils soient statique alors
qu'est ce qu'il a fait et ben il a
rajouté un terme à ces équations et en
fait ça c'était une connerie parce que
ça marchait même pas et quelques années
plus tard une fois que les observations
de
on était bien établie il a dû
reconnaître qu'ils s'étaient plantés il
a accepté l'expansion de l'univers
et il a supprimé le terme
supplémentaires qu'il avait ajouté et
même un peu plus tard il a appelé ça la
plus grosse erreur de sa vie alors
maintenant qu'on sait que l'univers est
en expansion une question qu'on peut se
poser c'est est-ce que ça va durer
encore longtemps
est-ce que ça va continuer comme ça est
ce que ça va s'arrêter un moment donné
et pour essayer de répondre à cette
question et ben on peut utiliser les
équations d'einstein est ce que nous
disent ces équations c'est que
l'expansion de l'univers
elle ne peut que décélérer alors il ya
quand même deux cas de figure possibles
soit elle va décélérer suffisamment
jusqu'à s'arrêter
et puis repartir en arrière c'est à dire
que l'univers va se mettre à se
contracter et il va finir dans ce qu'on
appelle parfois un big crunch par
opposition aux big bang soit l'expansion
va ralentir mais continuer éternellement
de plus en plus lentement mais sans
jamais s'inverser et l'univers va
devenir de moins en moins denses et de
plus en plus froid ça c'est le scénario
qu'on appelle parfois du big chill
legrand refroidissement alors même si
tout ça n'aura lieu que dans plusieurs
milliards d'années
on a quand même envie de savoir dans
laquelle des deux situations se trouvait
ce qu'on va finir en big crunch où est
ce qu'on va finir en big chill et en
fait pour savoir ça il faut connaître la
densité moyenne de l'univers si on est
au dessus d'une certaine valeur
ça sera un big crunch est en dessous ça
sera big chill est ce qu'il ya
d'étonnant c'est que chaque fois qu'on a
des observations astrophysiques qui nous
permettent de mesurer la densité de
l'univers on s'aperçoit qu'on est à
chaque fois à la limite entre les deux
scénarios un coin un petit peu au dessus
un coup un petit peu en dessous
enfin ça c'était avant 1997
parce qu'en 1997 a eu lieu une
observation extraordinaire qui a
complètement changé la donne
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé en 97 il
ya deux équipes d'astronomes qui
indépendamment ont fait une observation
incroyable ils ont mesuré que
l'expansion de l'univers était en fait
en train de s'accélérer
c'est à dire qu'on est dans aucun des
deux scénarios que je vous ai décrit
mais on est dans un troisième scénario
qui est plutôt comme ça donc ça c'est
assez bizarre puisque je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure d'après les équations
d'einstein l'expansion de l'univers ne
peut que décélérer et là on a des
observations qui nous disent qu'en fait
elle est en train de s'accélérer alors
comment c'est possible
alors en fait c'est possible d'expliquer
ça avec les équations d'einstein
à une condition de rajouter ce fameux
terme
kaïn stein avait introduit et qu'il
avait fini par supprimer en disant que
c'était la plus grande erreur de sa vie
ce terme qu'on appelle la constante
cosmologique et si on ajoute ce terme
aux équations d'einstein
ça colle parfaitement avec les
observations d'un univers en expansion
accélérée
alors si on est vraiment dans ce cas de
figure le destin de l'univers bas il
n'est pas vraiment meilleur que dans les
autres cas puisque l'univers va
continuer à s'étendre de plus en plus
vite et il va finir dans ce qu'on
appelle parfois le big rip le grand
déchirement
alors cette modification kaïn stein
avait introduit dans ces équations et
qu'il avait fini par supprimer en disant
que c'était la plus grande erreur de sa
vie
oui finalement elle va être
indispensable pour expliquer l'expansion
accélérée de l'univers
donc ça vaut le coup de se pencher un
petit peu plus sur ce terme c'est donc
quelque chose qu'on appelle la constante
cosmologique est une manière de
l'interpréter c'est de dire que le vide
possède une énergie
je suis d'accord c'est un petit peu
contre intuitif puisque à priori le vide
c'est le vide on ne voit pas très bien
pourquoi il y aurait une énergie
mais bon c'est quelque chose qu'on
observe expérimentalement donc à limite
pourquoi pas et grâce aux observations
astrophysiques on peut même calculer la
valeur de l'énergie du vide et on trouve
que cette énergie du vide
elle vaut environ 10 puissance -13 joule
par centimètre cube
alors la limite moi je veux bien
admettre que le vide possède une énergie
si c'est une idée qui colle avec les
observations astrophysiques pourquoi pas
mais il ya quand même quelque chose de
pas très satisfaisant dans cette idée
c'est cette énergie doit ce qu'elle
vient or il se trouve qu'il ya une
théorie qui a une réponse toute prête à
cette question et cette théorie c'est la
mécanique quantique
[Musique]
vous avez la mécanique quantique c'est
la théorie qui permet de décrire le
comportement des particules au niveau
microscopique et il ya une idée qui est
absolument centrale en mécanique
quantique c'est ce qu'on appelle le
principe d'incertitude de heisenberg ce
principe vous en avez peut-être déjà
entendu parler il dit qu'une particule
au niveau microscopique
elle ne peut pas avoir à la fois une
position et une vitesse parfaitement
défini est une des conséquences du
principe d'incertitude de heisenberg
c'est que les particules ne peuvent
jamais avoir une énergie qui soit
complètement nul
il ya toujours un petit quelque chose
qui reste un petit minimum d'énergie et
ce principe
il s'applique aussi aux champs
électromagnétiques est une des
conséquences de ça c'est que le vide
n'est jamais vide il ya toujours un tout
petit peu d'énergie associées un tout
petit peu de champ électromagnétique est
donc en mécanique quantique et ben le
vide possède une énergie est ce que
c'est un formidable ça on observe
l'énergie du vide en cosmologie à
travers l'expansion accélérée de
l'univers et la mécanique quantique nous
permet d'expliquer d'où vient cette
énergie au niveau microscopique
le problème c'est que si on fait le
calcul de la valeur de l'énergie du vide
en mécanique quantique ce qu'on trouve
c'est 10 puissance 107 joule par
centimètre cube une valeur monstrueuse
et je vous rappelle tout à l'heure on a
dit que la valeur observée
expérimentalement grâce à l'expansion de
l'univers c'était 10 puissance -13 joule
par centimètre cube c'est à dire que la
valeur trouvé par la mécanique quantique
elle est dix puissance 120 fois trop
grosse c'est à dire mille milliards de
milliards de milliards de milliards de
fois trop grosse
je pense qu'on peut dire sans problème
qu'il s'agit de la plus grosse erreur de
prédiction de toute l'histoire des
sciences
voilà vous attendez certainement ce que
je vous explique qu'on a facilement
trouvé d'où vient cette incohérence et
que les chercheurs ont résolu le
problème
et ben non personne n'en sait rien et
sachez que c'est même un des problèmes
les plus cruciaux aujourd'hui en
physique fondamentale d'expliquer
pourquoi l'énergie du vide observé
expérimentalement en cosmologie est
aussi petit
alors que le calcul théorique en
mécanique quantique est aussi gros et
pour répondre à cette question
voyez qu'il faut manier à la fois
l'infiniment grand et l'infiniment petit
unifiée mécanique quantique et
relativité générale et donc pour
répondre correctement à cette question
il est vraisemblable qu'il faille
disposer d'une théorie du tout et
aujourd'hui eh ben on la cherche
toujours
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo j'espère
que vous connaîtrez jamais d'erreurs
aussi grosse n'hésitez pas à partager la
vidéo pour m'aider à faire connaître la
chaîne vous pouvez aussi aller voir mes
vidéos précédentes notamment celle sur
stephen hawking et celle sur la théorie
des cordes et vous pouvez me retrouver
sur facebook sur twitter et sur mon blog
qui s'appelle science étonnante
merci et à bientôt
[Musique]